Jennifer Aniston rings in her 50th v-day
in a big way happy birthday Jim were
real the actors celebrated the big 500
at Sunset Tower Hotel in Los Angeles on
Saturday night yes and not only did we
have major FOMO we took a trip down
memory lane
seriously the 90s 2000s era of me came
alive so Jen's star-studded guest list
included Courtney Cox
Lisa Kudrow yes Rachel Monica and Phoebe
reunited George and Amal Clooney Robert
Downey jr. Ellen DeGeneres Katy Perry
Kate Hudson Reese Witherspoon Wow the
list goes on goes on now of course Reese
took a tumble after a night out partying
with her pals which means it must have
been a really good party honestly the
most relatable moment for me of the
night also there was going to Paltrow
who is like Jen and ex of Brad Pitt she
shared this snap caption
happy birthday last night and tomorrow -
Jennifer Aniston R ray of sunshine
example of Perpetual goodness we love
you so much and you make 50 look fired
now speaking of Brad he shocked the
world by showing up yes Brad and Jen
back together for one night only
yeah break out the team Jen shirts guys
now I witnessed LG team Brad arrive with
a security team and seemed to be in
quote a good mood the 55 year old tried
to keep a low profile as he entered the
birthday bash a source tells ety quote
he came on his own and quietly entered
the party they had heavy security kept a
ban on social media and hope for the
best but we're talking about it by now
you know why this is a big deal Jen and
Brad were married from 2000 to 2005 and
we all ship them so much and shortly
after Brad started dating Angelina Jolie
and eventually married her fast forward
to 2019 Brad and Jen are both single Wow
so our head Canon is going a little
crazy in 2017 following Pitt split from
Jolie a source told et that pitten
Aniston had been in touch adding they
are friends in February 2018 after
Aniston announced her split from
ex-husband Justin Theroux a source also
told ET that Aniston and Pitt were
absolutely not
together a source says Jen and Brad have
remained friends I have spoken with each
other quite a few times since they both
became single they are friends and have
supported each other through some tough
times
so here's the thing as much as we want
them together this these are exes so we
understand why that's probably not like
it was a while ago they're probably
different people like it's probably not
gonna happen but as an Entertainment
Tonight employee that would be the best
day of my entire career if these two got
back together oh my god same same things
okay so a source previously told et
they've come so far since marriage and
planned to stay friends for life they
both realize that any time they cross
paths people talk about a reunion which
is what we're doing which is exactly
what we're doing
oh yeah so UT spoke with Aniston in the
summer we actually asked her about her
50th birthday plans are you gonna like
what are you gonna do you're gonna well
apparently Ellen showing me my birthday
party so she did now she has to okay so
not sure Ellen had a hand in this party
but it looks like the place to be egg
was barren who was it well be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I met Courtney owners Cortez oh no
and I'm a - Crossen bye for now
[Applause]
you
[Music]